harta y confinada la gente volvió a
salir a las calles de trípoli por cuarta
noche consecutiva la indignación por las
restricciones contra la pandemia y el
consecuente empobrecimiento de la
población llevó a centenares de personas
a manifestarse unas manifestaciones que
se convirtieron en violentos
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad cócteles mólotov disparos
centenares de heridos entre el miércoles
y el jueves y al menos un muerto
lo que llevo a trípoli a esta situación
es que todas las otras ciudades se
enriquecieron a costa de trípoli no
tenemos donde ir no tenemos educación ni
atracciones turísticas el resto del
mundo puede protestar sin que le disparé
porque nosotros no la ira de la gente
las autoridades aseguran que la
represión contra las protestas era
necesaria igual que la nueva cuarentena
estricta sobre trípoli que agrava la
peor crisis económica que vive el líbano
pronto la gente está cansada es pobre
vive en la miseria y con la cuarentena
no hay trabajo
para los taxistas repartidores y
vendedores ambulantes el confinamiento
significa quedarse sin ingresos de hecho
la mitad del país trabaja en empleos
informales día a día
la crisis económica se superpone con la
sanitaria los hospitales luchan contra
la pandemia sin suministros suficientes
y cada vez hay menos camas disponibles